[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle édition de
présidentielle 360 voici les titres
françois fillon mise en examen le
candidat de la droite à la
présidentielle a été entendue dès ce
matin par les juges l'audition était
avancé de 24 heures pour qu'elle se
déroule dans des conditions de sérénité
selon son avocat il est poursuivi pour
détournement de fonds publics et abus de
biens sociaux analyses et réactions à
suivre marine le pen rattraper elle
aussi par une nouvelle affaire liée à la
sous-évaluation d'une partie de son
patrimoine à la présidente du fn serait
visé par deux procédures de redressement
fiscal alors que l'association anticor
demande des vérifications sur la
déclaration de patrimoine d'aimer
d'emmanuel macron alors qu'on vient de
l'apprendre le parquet de paris a décidé
également d'ouvrir une enquête pour
favoritisme
alors eh bien d'une soirée organisée par
emmanuel macron à las vegas
manuel valls va t'il à soutenir le
leader dans marches l'ancien président
l'ancien premier ministre réunit ses
soutiens ce soir très inquiet par la
campagne de benoît hamon qu'il juge
catastrophique est irréaliste et face à
la perspective de voir le fn au pouvoir
il pourrait sortir de son silence et
appelé à voter macron on en parle dans
cette édition et vous pouvez réagir sur
twitter à cette émission en direct
hashtag présidentielle à 360 pour
m'accompagner ce soir saveria rouge avec
en direct du sénat le multiplex s'est
tout de suite
la nouvelle a été confirmée en milieu
d'après midi par son avocat françois
fillon a été mise en examen pour
détournement de fonds publics et abus de
biens sociaux dans l' enquête sur les
soupçons d'emploi fictif de son épouse
et ses enfants comme assistant
parlementaire à monnières souci on
avance on d'un jour la convocation de
françois fillon les magistrats ont évité
aux candidats en face à face avec une
foule de journalistes devant les locaux
du parc et financier il a été reçu ce
matin en toute discrétion et mise en
examen notamment pour détournement de
fonds publics et recel d'abus de biens
sociaux
il n'a pas répondu au juge au cours de
cette audition mais a simplement lu une
déclaration où il a maintenu sa ligne de
défense
les enquêteurs concentrer sur les
soupçons d'emploi fictif de son épouse
et de ses enfants estime avoir assez
d'éléments pour poursuivre la procédure
les investigations se focalise sur les
activités de pénélope fillon dans son
rôle d'assistante parlementaire auprès
de son mari et de son suppléant marc
joulaud sur plusieurs périodes entre
1986 et 2013 les emploi d'assistant
occupé au sénat par deux des enfants de
françois fillon sont aussi scruté par la
justice l'enquète porte également sur la
collaboration de pénélope fillon à la
revue des deux mondes où elle a perçu
100 mille euros bruts entre mai 2012 et
décembre 2013
françois fillon avait dans un premier
temps promis de se retirer s'il était
mis en examen
il a depuis annoncé qu'il irait jusqu'au
bout c'est la première fois qu'un
candidat majeur à la présidentielle est
dans cette situation judiciaire en
pleine période électorale et on écoutait
tout de suite allé réaction au sénat
suite à cette mise en examen
réactions recueillies par héloïse et
grégoire la décision de mise en examen
n'est pas une décision sur la
culpabilité de la personne mise en
examen
fort heureusement d'ailleurs nous vivons
dans un pays où le juge d'instruction
instruit à charge et à décharge et par
conséquent nous tous citoyens français
elle nous devons respecter la justice de
notre pays et respecter la justice de
notre pays ça commence par le rappel des
règles fondamentales de la présomption
d'innocence
ce n'est pas une surprise ça fait 20 ans
qu'on s'y attendait il avait même
annoncé lui-même simplement ce que je
regretterai c'est finalement le débat
politique
reste encore à ce niveau là s'il s'agit
de monsieur fillon je préférerais qu'on
parle du fond de son programme de son
bilan ce que je demande à ses électeurs
est ce que je demande la responsabilité
c'est que finalement un
en tout état de cause à voir face à
marine le pen un candidat de cette
nature au deuxième tour serait un drame
absolu pour la démocratie française
et ouais tout de suite retrouvé savait
rien roseq en direct de la salle des
conférences du sénat saveria pour une
réaction avec pierre laurent secrétaire
national du parti communiste et sénateur
de paris
absolument bonjour pierre laurent
bonjour alors au qg 1,2 dans l'entourage
de françois fillon on parle de non
évènement sur cette mise en examen
quelle est votre réaction vous aura une
réaction évidemment choquée parce que
les les
les motifs de mise en examen sont quand
même très très lourd on savait que
françois fillon avait décidé de ne ne
pas de ne pas s'arrêter là et de
continuer sa campagne maintenant les
électeurs
1 les électeurs jugeront ce qui me
choque le plus dans cette affaire c'est
que quelqu'un qui visiblement a passé
beaucoup de temps à chercher à enrichir
sa famille continue de plaider pour un
programme d'une brutalité sociale inouïe
ça ne le gêne pas d'expliquer la veille
de sa mise en examen
alors qu'il est mise en cause pour des
faits qui qui sont quand même important
qu'il faut supprimer 500 mille
fonctionnaires est confirmé sa que les
salaires ça n'est pas une question que
les dépenses publiques y en a beaucoup
trop pour les familles modestes
voilà c'est ça qui me choque le plus
cette espèce dans des sens de l'argent
il n'est absolument plus légitime selon
vous à la fois pour défendre ce
programme et pour rester candidat
vous savez
j'ai jamais fait de françois fillon mon
candidat donc moi ce n'est pas moi à
décider de la légitimité de sa
candidature
j'ai combattu son programme et je pense
que puisqu'il veut aller devant les
électeurs malgré ces affaires et avec un
programme d'une telle brutalité mais il
faut battre ce programme dans les urnes
alors jean luc mélenchon que vous
défendez a obtenu alors on l'a appris
les 500 parrainages
néanmoins il stagne dans les sondages
annoncent pour s'en va demain mon lui
perd deux points à 14%
est ce que vous regrettez profondément
qui paye d'alliance entre ces deux
candidats pour justement garder une
chance d'être ce qu'on savait à quelques
semaines du premier tour je suis pas
dans le regret et moi je suis dans
l'action pour mobiliser je pense qu'il
faut que les votes de gauche montrent
tous les votes de gauche oui je n'étais
pas le mariage raté j'ai passé j'ai
passé un nom a essayé de me battre pour
qu'ils aient une seule candidature de
toute la gauche qui était d'accord pour
rompre avec le bilan du quinquennat donc
évidemment cette candidature nous manque
dans cette situation maintenant on est
dans le temps de la bataille
à quelques semaines du premier tour et
moi je vais faire tout mon possible pour
que les électeurs de gauche trouvent le
moyen de s'exprimer de la manière la
plus claire vous savez que je soutiens
la candidature de jean-luc mélenchon
je vais apporter mon parrainage mais je
continuerai à me battre pour la
convergence de tous les électeurs de
gauche qu'elle aidait n'a pas voulu
sacrifier pour l'autre
hu vous savez très bien que la logique
présidentielle a conduit et la manière
dont se sont construites les
candidatures a conduit les deux à se
revendiquer d'une légitimité qui les
empêchait de s'effacer c'est pour
prévenir ce risque là que j'avais
souhaité moi au départ que nous
construisions autrement les candidatures
je le répète aujourd'hui je sais qu'il
ya des gens qui continuent de réclamer
cette candidature commune
elle sera très difficile à obtenir il
faut donc maintenant essayer de
mobiliser l'ensemble des électeurs de
gauche moi je vais travailler à sa très
bien merci beaucoup pierre leman d'avoir
répondu à la question merci merci savait
rien pour cette réaction directe et je
vous le disais on titre le parquet de
paris ouvre une enquête préliminaire
pour favoritisme
suite au déplacement controversé à des
manies
macron à à las vegas comme tranier nous
a rejoint sur ce plateau bonjour soir
tam
on va parler dans un instant des
déclarations de patrimoine des candidats
mais d'abord une vérification une
clarification
suite à ces deux informations puisqu'on
nous dit aujourd'hui que marine le pen
serait sous le coup de deux
redressements fiscaux alors est
sous-évalué une partie de son patrimoine
et puis l'association anticor demande
aussi de vie rêvée des vérifications
pardon sur la déclaration de patrimoine
des manuels macro alors déjà
effectivement une clarification c'est
que nous ne disposons pas à l'heure
actuelle des déclarations de patrimoine
à des candidats à l'élection
présidentielle en vue de la
présidentielle
en effet ils ont jusqu'au 17 mars pour
déposer ses déclarations auprès du
conseil constitutionnel
des déclarations qui seront ensuite
rendues publiques au minimum 15 jours
avant le premier tour de l'élection
c'est à dire le 9 avril
conclusion aujourd'hui nous disposons
des déclarations de patrimoine des
candidats six ont été parlementaires ou
par exemple pour emmanuel macron comme
ancien ministre en mai c'est donc sur la
déclaration de patrimoine de l'ancien
ministre de l'économie
quand il aura des doutes effectivement
plus précisément sur sa déclaration d'
octobre 2014 qui est disponible en ligne
et bien je le regardais j'ai calculé
suis arriver à peu près aux mêmes
chiffres qu'anticor entre 2009 et 2014
et bien emmanuel macron a été banquier
d'affaires chez rothschild puis il a été
secrétaire général adjoint de l'elysée
en additionnant tous ses revenus on
arrive à 3,3 millions d'euros son
patrimoine aussi est disponible et lui
s'élève en additionnant tous qu'il ya
sur ces comptes et également la valeur
d'achat de son appartement un peu moins
d'1 2 million d'euros
or emmanuel macron est endetté on voit
sur sa déclaration à hauteur de plus
d'un million d'euros ce qui fait un
patrimoine à net de seulement 200 mille
euros
et ça ça suscite selon anticor des
interrogations interrogations justifié
selon vous m écoutez c'est impossible à
partir des seules déclarations de la
haute autorité pour la transparence de
la vie publique il y a beaucoup
d'informations qui manquent
on ne sait pas comment il a pu être
dépensé son argent c'est la hache fait
peut-être de rembourser un emprunt
important avant 2014 ou encore s'il a pu
avoir beaucoup d'impôts à payer
c'est d'ailleurs la défense de manuel
macron c'est qu'il a été indépendant
pendant une partie de sa carrière comme
un ben khedda sari dont
qu'il a dû payer des cotisations
patronales des cotisations sociales et
des impôts rothschild selon lui n'aurait
pas rapporter 3 millions d'euros de
revenus mais la moitié possible pour
anticorps qui estime cependant qu'il
faut demander des déclas des départs
dont des clarifications au fisc et le
fisc qui est justement demande aussi des
comptes à la famille le pen
et là il faut être précis on ne parle
pas simplement de doute mais
véritablement d'un redressement fiscal
en cours pour le fils qui vient la
famille le pen à sous-estimer la valeur
du domaine de montretout les le pen
estime le domaine à deux millions et
demi d'euros pour le fisc et bien c'est
deux fois plus et le problème c'est
qu'en 2012 et bien jean marie le pen a
donné une partie de ce domaine à marine
le pen
une partie elle aussi sous-évalué et
donc l'administration réclame 60 remets
63000 euros à marine le pen noter qu'en
plus de cela
jean marine le pen et marine le pen ont
fait l'objet d'un signalement de la
haute autorité au parc à financer pour
des déclarations patrimoine de 2014
mais là on ne peut pas vérifier car
cette déclaration de patrimoine ne sont
pas rendus publics pour les
parlementaires européens à faire assume
donc merci beaucoup d'âme
les deux hommes ont longtemps été un
ennemi au sein du gouvernement manuel
valls emmanuel macron pourrait néanmoins
enterré la hache de guerre le temps de
la campagne le candidat malheureux de la
primaire ps refuse de soutenir benoît
hamon comme il s'y était engagé et
chaque jour qui passe est bien le
rapproche un peu plus du leader du
leader dans marche à l'aide de chiens
la rupture entre les gauches
irréconciliables sera t elle bientôt
consommer à en croire le journal le
parisien
manuel valls s'apprête à soutenir
emmanuel macron à la présidentielle une
information aussitôt démentie
ceci est faux a tweeté le député carlos
da silva un proche de l'ancien premier
ministre dans le camp de benoît hamon on
temporise en rappelant les engagements
de la primaire je crois qu'à partir du
moment où il s'est engagé dans le
processus de la primaire après il peut
le regretter ou pas mais il a pris cet
engagement et s'éteint c'est un homme de
parole c'est un homme d'état donc la
première des qualités d'un homme d'état
c'est de respecter
justement cette cette parole donnée donc
je crois que là-dessus il a été clair en
démentant cet
rumeurs manuel valls a aussi laissé
entendre à paris match qu'il ne
donnerait pas son parrainage à benoît
hamon mais dans le camp d'emmanuel
macron son éventuel soutien est jugé
plutôt encombrant si ce choix est fait
ce qu'il fallait sur des bases claires
c'est à dire que ne pas y avoir deux
bémols 6ème manuel valls dit si tu te
soutenir emmanuel macron qu'ils le
fassent
je ne pense pas aujourd'hui qui toi dans
cet état d'esprit s'il le fait il le
fera de façon si le fait de façon très
claire qu'il n'y aura pas d'ambiguïté et
dans ce cadre là tous les soutiens sont
les bouts mais certains soutiens sont
plus souhaité que d'autres à commencer
par celui de jean yves le drian qui
devrait annoncer cette semaine son
ralliement à emmanuel macron et serge
raffy m'a rejoint sur ce plateau bonsoir
et éditorialiste à l'ops hauteur de
nicolet les vampires paru en 2007 aux
éditions robert laffont va commencer
avec vous bien sûr cette mise en examen
alors on voit qu'elle était attendue
ce n'est pas vraiment une surprise il
reste la présomption d'innocence pour le
candidat si on pour autant est-ce que
c'est un véritable tournant dans cette
campagne présidentielle aujourd'hui on
sait plus où sont les tournants il ya
tellement de virages que l'on s'y perd
un peu on est vraiment dans les têtes à
queue permanent donc c'est très
compliqué ce qu'on voit par contre
aujourd'hui c'est que quand même les
magistrats ont fait un effort
c'est à dire qu'ils ont évité à françois
fillon un barnum médiatique le cirque le
grand spectacle de la mise en examen de
françois fillon et bien il y a échappé
donc on peut dire que les juges ont été
plutôt cléments
dans cet aspect des choses puisque
aujourd'hui la justice elle est dans un
temps mais ne le fait d'avoir avancé
cette audition on peut apparenter
sagesse aussi sur une forme d'indulgence
une forme de un geste qui va dans le
sens de l'apaisement politique
maintenant le dossier judiciaire
il est strictement le même et personne
ne pouvait douter avec tous les éléments
qu'il ya pour le moment dans l' enquête
que la mise en examen se ferait donc on
est dans le cas où des magistrats trois
magistrats sont quand même quelque part
convaincu que la responsabilité et la
culpabilité de françois fillon peut être
sérieusement envisagée donc c'est quand
même un boulet terrifiant pour un
candidat à la présidence de la
république
ce que les
les dirigeants de l air avait anticipé
et savait pertinemment qu'ils allaient
se retrouver dans un cas de figure
cauchemardesque c'est à dire défendre un
candidat sans y croire vraiment on le
voit bien c'est à dire que rappelez-vous
les têtes d'enterrement de toute la
direction de l heure quand ils ont quand
ils ont appris que françois fillon ne
lâcherai pas et on avait l'impression
qu'on était à des funérailles nationales
or le kamikaze continue sa route c'est
quelque chose va continuer comme
jusqu'au premier tour puisque on a vu
encore cet après midi devant les
associations de chasseurs et bien comme
si de rien n'était il a continué
justement sa campagne cette stratégie
est elle encore tenable c.longo bien
sedan mais il va continue les jeux sont
faits les dépôts de candidatures sont
imminents on est à quelques jours des
dépôts donc la droite ne peut plus se
retourner il ya plus de candidats de
substitution
on est les blés plan b c d y z ça
n'existe pas adrian de revoir les gps
les sarkozystes remonter au créneau et
le maître de nous bien sûr que non ils
ont une espèce de deux candidats comment
dirais-je qui est dans le couloir de la
mort judiciaire c'est quelque chose
d'inouï et ils sont acceptés cette
situation là moi je n'en reviens pas je
n'arrive pas encore à comprendre comment
la direction du mouvement des
républicains a pu se laisser comment
dirais-je presque tromper une espèce de
prise en otage de françois fillon sur le
dossier judiciaire espérant qu'il va
absolument s'en sortir grâce à
l'élection présidentielle ce qui paraît
quand même très mal engagé visuellement
devant les juges il a redit bien et bien
que l'emploi de son épouse n'étaient pas
fictifs
il peut aurait bénéficié d'un non lieu
ici l élection présidentielle
ça me paraît quand même délicat
un non-lieu d'ici l'élection
présidentielle non il va y avoir de
toute manière à partir du moment où
imaginons la situation où il est élu
président de la république ce qui
aujourd'hui est quand même assez
improbable parce que les dynamiques de
campagne sont quand même largement
engagé bien sûr il peut y avoir un coup
de tonnerre encore une nouvelle une
nouvelle catastrophe
vous n'y croyez pas justement du fait de
cette mise en examen s'avère l'empêcher
d'accéder au second tour vous je pense
que le calendrier judiciaire va se
poursuivre et on ne sait pas quelles
seront les nouvelles révélations qui
peuvent encore se faire dans les jours
qui viennent les juges vont continuer à
laisser enquêter napoli la police ils
sont trois à relancer un peu les
investigations
on ne sait pas comment elles vont se
diriger mais ça me paraît très très
difficile vu les éléments qui sont quand
même à charge contre françois fillon je
ne vois pas comment il peut à chapet à
cette espèce de supplice chinois
il est mis au pilori ça c'est vrai mais
cette mise au pilori quelque part il s'y
est mis volontairement c'est à dire que
c'est pour ça que j'utilise le mot de la
stratégie du kamikaze
c'est que il prend tous les risques
alors il est surprenant il est même
assez stupéfiant cet homme là parce
qu'il est beaucoup plus solide qu'on le
croyait
mais en même temps il a pris son camp en
otage dans des proportions absolument
inégalée on n'a jamais vu ça dans
l'histoire de la vème république
justement sur ce point que c'est inédit
en fait mise en examen aucun candidat
n'a jamais réussi à être élu en étant
mise en examen surtout on est aussi dans
le cas de figure où quand même un
candidat élu à la primaire désigné à la
primaire dans des conditions légitimes
tout à fait légal est très largement
légitime puisqu'il habite arrivé à près
de 60% des voix au second tour contre
alain juppé mais en même temps sur une
ligne politique qui n'est pas du tout
celle de la direction de son propre
parti il s'est radicalisé pendant toute
cette période pour aller chercher
justement un électorat qui n'avaient pas
l'habitude de récupérer on a parlé de la
droite traditionnelle une droite très
conservatrice il est dans cette logique
là est dans une logique de
radicalisation de ces propos donc sans
problème ça va être justement un moment
donné de trouver un curseur un peu
différent pour aller chercher des voix
au centre
mais la question c'est est-ce que les
voies du sens ne sont pas partis déjà et
depuis est pourtant un accord a été
signé cet après midi avec jean
christophe lagarde avec la lune et y les
les accords d'appareil c'est une chose
et puis la réalité de l'électorat de la
droite française c'est une chose très
différentes et l'électorat du centre eh
bien je crois que tout l'épisode qu'ils
ont vécu avec françois fillon sait de
pénélope gabe absolument inouïe eh bien
je ne crois pas que ça les attirera vers
françois fillon deux autres candidats
sont aussi rattrapé par les affaires on
l'évoqué à l'instant marine le pen avec
ses redressements fiscaux emmanuel
macron voit que le parquet de paris
s'intéressent et bien à ce déplacement à
las vegas où il y aurait une soirée
organisée par havas sans appel d'offres
et la huent aussi une nouvelle enquête
pour favoritisme ça va peser dans cette
campagne ce climat des affaires mais
bien sûr ça prouve qu'il ya un climat
pourri dans cette élection
présidentielle et je trouve ça
particulièrement dangereux pour la
démocratie
parce que ça ne ce n'est pas la faute
des juges pascal or là il faudrait voir
comment la justice est souvent
instrumentalisés par des adversaires par
qui justement profitent de cette période
là pour affaiblir le candidat d'en face
à ce problème que nous vivons
aujourd'hui il a existé bien avant mais
là simplement il est concentré il dans
une période trop dur et surtout il est
porté par un candidat de la droite qui
lui quand même est un état est un boulet
terrible pour sa propre famille donc ça
veut dire que la droite française jeu
aujourd'hui risque d'être éliminée au
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle ce qui serait totalement
nouveau et ce qui n'est pas bon de toute
manière quoi qu'il arrive pour la
démocratie
eh bien merci beaucoup et serge raffy
pour votre éclairage
michel grossiord nous rejoint tout de
suite sur ce plateau bonsoir michel dans
un instant l'épreuve de rites vérité
pardon l'émission politique de la
rédaction de public sénat et vous
recevez ce soir gérard larcher le
président du sénat
et bien sûr on poursuivre la
conversation que vous avez un instant
avec serge raffy
qu'est ce que ça change cette mise en
examen du candidat selon gérard larcher
est ce que ça fragilise un peu plus
françois fillon on lui demandera
également s'il peut espérer rassembler
la famille du centre élargir son
électorat
on interrogera également sur le
programme de françois fillon gérard
larcher présenté comme la toux social du
candidat mais après les propositions
dévoilées hier par le candidat est ce
que ce sera l'austérité pour tous voilà
ce qu'on demandera notamment à gérard
larcher on parlera également et bien sûr
des mesures envisagées pour la
moralisation de la vie publique et
politique
un beau programme michel ce sera donc à
suivre sur notre antenne en direct à
partir de 18h30 dans le reste de
l'actualité le parlement britannique a
validé hier le déclenchement du brésil
quelques heures après theresa may la
première ministre a répété qu'elle
déclencherait le fameux article 50
synonyme de divorce avec l'union
européenne avant le 31 mars
malgré les velléités de l'ecosse de
recourir à un autre référendum cécile 6
au times of the prime minister
[Musique]
elle devait donner une date précise mais
finalement theresa may attendra
l'assentiment royal avant fin mars pour
mettre en marche le break nous allons
commencer à penser à la confirmation
royal dans les jours qui nous restons
sur la bonne voie avec le calendrier que
j'ai servi via six mois et je reviendrai
devant cette chambre avant la fin de
semaine après le vote hier par le
parlement britannique theresa may devait
pourtant aller vite mais les cos est
venu semer le trouble en demandant la
clé d'un nouveau référendum
d'indépendance avec tristesse nécessaire
et je vais donc faire le nécessaire pour
m'assurer que les corses aura un choix à
faire à la fin de ce processus
un choix entre suivre et le royaume uni
dans un brésil dur ou devenir un pays
indépendant capable de s'assurer d'un
partenariat à égalité avec le royaume
uni et l'europe
un référendum qui pourrait provoquer
l'éclatement du royaume uni je pense que
ça affaiblit la position de theresa may
parce que ça voudrait dire que si elle
suit la voie d'un bric site dur on
pourrait finir avec une prise
constitutionnel est probablement
l'implosion du royaume uni
theresa may a faibli et le plus dur
reste à faire car une fois la procédure
enclenchée elle devra négocier avec les
vingt sept sur trois points cruciaux le
paiement de la sortie du royaume uni de
l'union le statut des ressortissants et
la nature des relations commerciales
culturel et diplomatique des discussions
qui devront être bouclés dans deux ans
et vous le savez le sénat suit de près 1
le travail est bien les sûr avec un
groupe de travail le bret exit les
sénateurs avaient entendu récemment
hubert védrine l'ancien ministre des
affaires étrangères qui n'avait pas
caché ses inquiétudes d'une sortie du
royaume-uni de lieux on écoute
dans la sphère du breakbeat
j'incite mans à la prudence dans
l'analyse parce qu'il me semble qu'on
personne n'a la moindre idée de ce que
sera la position et la grande bretagne
et de l'union européenne dans six mois
un an un an et demi deux ans on voit
bien aujourd'hui que c'est complètement
impossible de prévoir des élections à 3
mois ou six mois
bon il ya une sorte de phénomène que
j'appelle d'insurrection électorale dans
le lent semble du monde occidental et
européens donc soyons prudents dans
l'immédiat madame mais ne peut pas dire
autre chose que ce qu'elle dit elle est
contrainte par le référendum par le
résultat du référendum et donc et
l'obligé dire ce qu'elle nie c'est
compliqué je passe sur tous les
problèmes de gestion interne de sa
majorité la question du rôle des juges
par rapport au rôle de parent le bonbon
tout son article 55 déclencher un moment
donné il y aura un processus et après
qu'est ce qui va se passer on n'en sait
absolument rien moi j'écarte pas
l'hypothèse qui est un engrenage vers
une sortie d'irrémédiable oui possible
mais l'inversé n'est pas exclue
ces termes que les britanniques encore
une fois pas maintenant elle peut pas
mais dans un certain temps dans un an
par exemple 10
on a eu un mandat du peuple pour
négocier la sortie finalement c'est
infaisable trop compliqué ce n'est que
des inconvénients on n'y arrive pas donc
le pourquoi pas revenir à une autre
ligne vous ne tuez pas si je n'exclus
pas je peux pas le prouver puisque j'en
sais rien en fait fondamentalement
encore une fois c'est peut-être
l'engrenage de la sortie que l'on
appelle du rire et mais diable qui va
s'imposer
puis tout le monde se traite de noms
d'oiseaux donc au bout d'un moment il ya
plus d esprit de conciliation de
compromis mais je n'exclus pas l'autre
ligne en fait sur lalinde et les
britanniques dirait brogno référendum
mais après tout les légitimités c'est
surtout le parlement la situation a
changé eu des élections en france en
allemagne ceci cela donc on peut
peut-être reprendre le sujet mais je
vous parle plutôt de 2018 que 2017 et je
n'exclus pas de l'autre côté du côté des
européens qui aujourd'hui sont très
dures en disant on va être très
exigeants ils peuvent pas avoir le
beurre et l'argent du beurre
donc une position un peu
un peu sèche un peu punitive même du
côté français voire même allemands et
c'est ce qui explique michel barnier et
danser le mandat ou verhofstadt mais qui
est un fédéraliste dur donc c'est normal
qu'ils s'expriment comme ça je suis pas
du tout sûr que ce soit la ligne
dominante en europe dans un an on peut
pas du tout à exclure notamment après
des élections allemandes que l'allemagne
justement qui est aujourd'hui dé facto
pour 36 raison position en arbitre 10
après tout c'est trop papillon de se
priver de la grande bretagne donc il
faut qu'on repense tout ça donc moi je
ne regarde pas l'hypothèse où les cartes
seraient redistribuées en 2018 mais je
connais certains alors je sais pas ce
qu'il ya dans le compte-rendu on fera
attention mais certains experts vous dis
c'est ce que madame mais ce père au fond
d'elle-même sommes en captation vidéo
youtube ont très bien et donc certains
experts mais qui peuvent pas le prouver
dit certains jambes et même sur la ligne
dure madame ait dit ça peut tourner
comme ça c'est la fin de cette émission
merci à vous de m'avoir suivi tout de
suite l'épreuve de vérité invité ce soir
chez le président du sénat bonne soirée
à tous et à demain 18h
[Musique]
il